Wow yeah yeah we just did three yeah
yeah every much yeah maybe did 99
something like that but I did a hundred
and forty-eight fear factors Wow and I
did six more than we did when when it
came back and six or seven more I think
it did we did seven that 48 yeah that
was preposterous that was when I was
losing my mind wasn't even one a day or
was it less than oh no one took three
days sometimes you could bang out one in
two days like you could have the Beast
on early in the day in the sea stunts at
night like the final stunt at night
that's my you know what again very
fortunate it was a great gig plenty of
money and it was all good and it
definitely helped my stand-up coz gave
me [ __ ] you money too
it gave me the ability to not worry
about like having money in the bank
because I don't have like extravagant
tastes I'm not too ridiculous with money
but I like feeling like I don't have to
worry like as soon as you know okay good
don't think about that anymore now think
about other things so it really helped
me there and also the preposterous nosov
it was a boundless source of material
yeah which is such a ridiculous show
that I hosted a spin-off that didn't get
picked up what was it called say uncle
what's his show - and I was writing on
the man show and that's how I knew David
Hurwitz who's produced some fear factor
and they had a show called say uncle
which I later parodied in the De Niro
movie I wrote the comedian called like
stop uncle or whatever it was but anyway
the the big one of the big things was a
guy a contestant got in a turkey pen
mm-hmm and we like put maple syrup all
over when he rolled around in these like
birds like pecked at him and he's his
family's there watching and he starts
bleeding and she's and I stopped the
thing and the producers were man that
you can't stop in the middle of like the
guy's crying I go yeah it was just a
total disaster you could tell it was
gonna be a big hit but it was risky and
then I remember going to Jimmy Kimmel's
like premiere party for Jimmy Kimmel
Live and I saw the head of ABC there and
I'd never done this in my entire life
they use like getting a drink and I
Dober and i said please don't pick it up
yeah it's rough it's gonna be it's gonna
be too hard to stand behind we're
torturing people well they didn't pick
it up he just kind of looked at me and
smiled here's this this would have been
2003 hmm yeah that was right after fear
factor was first launched when when
those shows what happens is you get used
to one thing and so you have to do
something that's bigger and better the
next year yeah and so when we came back
I felt uncomfortable with a lot of the
[ __ ] they know how to do it like the
stunt guys are top of the food chain
they but they were doing some sketchy
[ __ ] like one of them we had these
people chained to a tree look with
bungee cords that were attached to a
helicopter and they had to figure out
the right locks to unlock the bungee
cord that there the straps to keep them
to the tree and then as soon as they do
they undo the strap and push they go
[ __ ] shooting out into space into the
center of this gigantic canyon and
they're bouncing underneath this router
and I remember thinking like this
doesn't yeah if we could do this a
thousand times one of them someone's
gonna die of course one of them
someone's gonna die and it might be the
next one it never have we got lucky dude
I really feel like we got lucky I really
really honestly 100% feel like we got
lucky there was a few things first of
all you there's a certain amount of risk
that you take whenever you're doing
anything like jump your car off of a
building roof which we did we had people
fly cars across a train a moving train
okay there's risk involved in that right
but the one that scared the [ __ ] out of
me the most was bull riding we had
people ride bulls it was the only time I
told contestants don't do it I'm like if
you if you want to ask me I would say
don't do it na nare no no no no before
we know on air I mean I gave them the
standard right but when you know what I
would talk to them I'd say look this is
up to you right if you want to go on me
people do know how to ride bulls but you
know how to ride a bull we're not
teaching you how to ride a bull you're
not going through classes you're not
slowly there surely building up your
techniques right you're just gonna ride
a bull right don't do that right don't
do that that's what I would say and we
had this girl she was like
98 pounds she got launched off the back
of this bowl and she'll do this these
people went [ __ ] flying like that that
thing's kicking gonna add a fall to
their yeah barely misses them when it's
kicking I mean they're wearing helmets
and [ __ ] but look at this look at this
look I mean come on man look at this I
mean that's that default the way she
felt like that that is like getting hit
in the back of the head with the world
yeah so like my personal feelings about
trauma and about what's dangerous and
[ __ ] like this this is a no-no
especially for a 90-pound woman like
this poor lady oh my goodness she got up
cute little fella I was back then yeah
she got up man she was tough as [ __ ] but
everybody I feel like in that one I feel
like we got lucky I feel like we rolled
the dice because if they stomp you they
lacerate livers and cry yeah crushed
sardines and they can stop you the funny
thing was those stunt guys are so
[ __ ] tough those guys are so used to
putting their ass on the line that they
don't think anything about someone doing
something risky right to them that's
what you do you showed up for work right
and that's definitely a different in
your head like an alpha or something
their animals have to do that like
fighting crave that like wonder what
we're saying you know does it keep them
from having a family there's a woman
who's gonna marry you if you're throwing
your life on the line unrelated to war
or famine no I think there's a certain
allure to remember that TV show the fall
guy yeah
how about Evel Knievel yeah I loved them
women loved Evel Knievel if that's a
good point
women love risk takers they like being
Amex guys to do those flips and [ __ ] and
those guys are those guys really [ __ ]
and now they have the parkour guys where
they like climb up a building would know
any any any kind of you could smoke you
could do parkour iron iron grid do